[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM MCGRATH: Welcome to
"Cloud OnAir," live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We host webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Tom
McGrath, and I'm joined
by Feng Lu, software engineer
from the Cloud Composer team.
And today we'll be talking
about Cloud Composer,
and how it orchestrates
containers, and even more.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
So our agenda today.
We'll be looking at an overview
of Cloud Composer and Apache
Airflow.
We'll look at how to
use Cloud Composer.
We'll also see what's
new in the GA release.
Feng will provide
an awesome demo.
We'll also look at some DAG
examples of advanced concepts.
And then from there are
next steps and roadmap,
and where to find out more.
So what is Cloud Composer?
As a starting point,
let's understand the fit
for Cloud Composer by
looking at the state
of the industry for a moment.
There's a lot of data today.
I think we can all
agree about that.
But how much data exactly?
Well, IDC estimates 163
zettabytes of data--
that's 163 billion terabytes--
will exist by 2025.
That's a lot, right, Feng?
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
So organizations are heavily
investing in public cloud
and currently are planning to
adopt public cloud strategies.
But at the same
time, they're going
to continue with some of
their on-premises investments
as well.
So it's very clear that a
hybrid cloud strategy is
necessary in this environment.
With the need for
a hybrid strategy
and before Cloud Composer,
there were a few ways
of managing workflows
across systems or even
on the Google Cloud Platform.
And I think it's fair to say
these were not the best at all.
FENG LU: No, not at all.
I wrote one of those stacks.
It's a pain.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah, I mean--
FENG LU: It's not a
workflow solution.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah, exactly.
Even just creating and
scheduling Cron jobs
and managing those,
or even going
to the other end of the
spectrum of creating
your own orchestration engine.
It's just a lot of work with
a high cost of ownership.
FENG LU: Absolutely.
Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
So the Cloud
Composer team rightly
thought it should be easy to
create, schedule, and monitor
robust portable workflows
that work inside
and outside of
Google Cloud Platform
for a holistic
workflow lifecycle.
So all these items
highlighted in blue
are key and critical
for a workflow.
It's more than a schedule
and just let it run,
or any one of these items.
It's all of them together.
So we're aiming to provide
organizations a solution that
covers them all.
And that's where Cloud
Composer fits, which was just
made generally available.
Nice work, Feng and team.
FENG LU: Thank you.
TOM MCGRATH: Yep.
And so it was just made
available inside of Google
Cloud Platform.
And the short version
of Cloud Composer
is that it's managed
Apache Airflow.
So why Cloud Composer?
End-to-end GCP integration,
orchestrate your full pipeline
through Cloud Composer.
And we want to make
sure that we supported
those hybrid and multi-cloud
environments that we're
seeing in the marketplace,
where these things are
just important to everyone.
We also want it to be very easy.
Not have to wrangle
with lots of code.
Be able to leverage Python
to be able to orchestrate
these workflows, and not have to
write a lot of that code that's
necessary.
But also keep it open source.
We want people to
contribute and be
part of the larger community.
FENG LU: Right.
Exactly.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
So a common question
is, well, what's
the difference
between Airflow manage
and running it on some VMs?
Well, what the team
has done is they've
created a seamless and
integrated experience with GCP.
So it's not standalone,
and it does not
feel like a standalone product.
Security, IAM, audit logging--
all those things are baked
in, so it acts and feels
like an actual Cloud product.
It's also easy to use
when things go as not
expected within your workflows.
And so Stackdriver is integrated
for that exact reason.
And we make it easy to
manage the deployment
with setting
environment variables
and maintaining your
Python packages.
Some of you might not be
familiar with Airflow,
or may have just heard of it.
So we're really
excited about it,
and we want you to see
why it's so exciting.
So Airflow is currently
in incubating as an Apache
Software Foundation project.
It's actually been
around for a few years.
It's a leading
open-source package
to create and
schedule workflows.
So all the workflows in
it are code with Python,
and they're highly approachable.
And you can do a lot
with it, including
some programmatic workflows.
And we'll actually look through
some quick, simple examples,
and you'll see how easy it is
to work with the code in Python
for Airflow.
So the strengths of Airflow
in the open-source community--
we wanted to bring
those together
with the strengths of
Google Cloud Platform.
As you can see on the right-hand
side, Google Cloud Platform--
we're great at running
infrastructure, creating
services, adding
layers of security,
auditability, and
containing costs.
But there is no workflow
and orchestration solution.
Airflow, on the other hand,
has really strong workflow
orchestration and connectors
inside and outside of GCP--
description language,
defined APIs, and so on.
So we wanted to
bring them together,
but also we wanted to contribute
back to the community.
And a great example of that
is the KubernetesPodOperator,
which we'll cover
later on in the demo.
So within Airflow,
the key concepts.
All workflows are
graphs, series of tasks,
and a task that can
fit into a graph.
It can be as simple as a
Bash script to tell the time.
Of course, they get plenty
more complicated from there.
Graphs can have a
series of tasks,
and tasks are basically a step.
For example, maybe I want to run
a SQL query or a BigQuery query
and export that to
Google Cloud Storage.
There's also the
concept of a sensor--
a Boolean check on a step
that waits until something
has completed.
When true, it precedes.
So we can orchestrate our
workflows very seamlessly
using these Airflow concepts.
With the DAG views
inside of Airflow,
it makes it very
easy to understand
your workflow and
its properties,
including any
bottlenecks or errors.
And really, what
this allows you to do
is chart a path to
higher reliability
of your orchestration workflows.
So in terms of additional
Airflow functionality--
connections.
There's all sorts of different
connections from Airflow
into other systems.
We talked a lot about
logging and being
able to see what's going on
within Airflow, but also SLAs,
whether or not you're
actually meeting those or not.
There's also the capability of
passing values between tasks.
So lots of interesting and
advanced functionality.
And usually there's some
questions of, can Airflow do x?
And usually the answer is yes.
FENG LU: Yeah.
Although it often
means that you may
need to-- either the
existing operators.
You don't often you
have to try to come up
with your own solution.
That tends to be hard,
but it's still possible.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: It's a
very flexible platform.
FENG LU: Yep.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
In terms of Google
Cloud Platform,
there's a core set of
Airflow support built
in-- so Dataflow connectors,
BigQuery, Cloud Storage
to name a few.
And support is
actually expanding
with each Airflow release.
And this is happening
within the Airflow team,
but also within the
Google Cloud team.
So what about support
outside of GCP?
Really important.
So for example, I can
run Bash commands.
I can call other public clouds.
I can connect into
JIRA, or even Slack,
for example, to send
notifications and interact
with those tools.
And there's so many
more under development.
So much support for
non-Google things,
fully usable within Airflow,
and thus Cloud Composer as well.
So in terms of some of the
new Cloud Composer features,
it's been made available
in a few new regions.
Stackdriver logging has been
very much expanded, which
we'll see within the demo.
There's also been the inclusion
of additional IAM roles.
And then additional future
additions in Airflow.
So the KubernetesPodOperator
brought in,
Parquet source format, and
also location selection
for Cloud Dataflow jobs.
So more and more
functionality being
added in with Cloud
Composer, and I
think you can see that
with this GA release.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
So what does using Cloud
Composer look like?
So you create a Cloud Composer
environment within a project.
Each environment is a managed
deployment of Apache Airflow,
so you don't have to worry
about the installation
and some other typical
administrative tasks.
FENG LU: Exactly.
That's why we created a
Cloud Composer to start with.
TOM MCGRATH: Definitely, right?
That takes a little bit
of uplift, right, Feng?
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
FENG LU: Totally.
TOM MCGRATH: And
projects can contain
more than one environment.
And so these integrate with
multiple different services--
Cloud Storage to
manage your workflows,
Stackdriver to understand
what's happening
within the environment.
And then, of course, we're
securing the environment
with IAM, which we'll
explain in a moment.
So functionality-wise,
these different methods
of accessing Cloud
Composer-- all the same.
One of the things that's
interesting to point out,
though, is with the
SDK, we've actually
made it convenient to
manage Composer and Airflow
both from the same
command line tool.
So with G Cloud,
having that installed,
I can then run my
Airflow commands
against my environment.
FENG LU: Exactly.
Isn't that cool?
TOM MCGRATH: That's awesome.
That's awesome
that you guys were
able to pull that together.
You have the tunnel
and the commands just
flow right through.
FENG LU: Right.
TOM MCGRATH: And you can manage
everything in the same place.
Super easy.
So when we look at
the architecture,
it's really a collection
of GCP resources.
So you'll notice off the bat
that there's two projects.
There's a customer
project and then
there's the tenant project.
The former is visible.
The customer project, you see
that running within your Cloud
Console.
The tenant project is
actually managed by GCP.
So that was a design
decision made because
of Airflow's microservice feel.
Do you want to comment on
that really quick, Feng?
FENG LU: Oh, yeah.
So there are Airflow
construct service
made up of a few components.
They have a web server,
they have a scheduler,
they have a worker.
So a different
microservice component
needs to run [INAUDIBLE] phase
into different GCP services.
For example, like
with web server,
naturally fit into
the [? GA ?] domain.
Likewise for scheduling
worker, sometimes those
need to communicate.
You need to have the right--
it's good that we can fit
those into our GCP service that
provides communication
from [INAUDIBLE] app.
And Google Kubernetes
clusters will be a good place
to host some of those
Airflow resources.
TOM MCGRATH: Absolutely.
And being able to scale up
and scale down is necessary.
FENG LU: Exactly.
Right.
TOM MCGRATH: One of
the other things that I
like about the design
too is that when
we look at the
Airflow database, that
was obscured away
in a tenant project,
so it could be secured down.
Because when we think about
connections to other systems,
we don't want those
connection details to get out.
We want those locked
down and secured away,
and by keeping it away
in the tenant project,
that's taken care of basically.
FENG LU: Right.
So here we really tried
to restrict the access
to your Airflow
[INAUDIBLE] database,
because it contains a lot
of connection credentials.
But at the same time, I
realize that sometimes you do
need to get a database access.
That is entirely possible by
downloading for the Kubernetes
engine that you use to run
your Airflow deployment.
TOM MCGRATH: Right.
Exactly.
And one other things I also
think that's really cool
is that when you think
about the things that
are inside the
tenant project, those
are things that
don't necessarily
need to be touched, right?
They can just operate and run,
and that's all well and good
from a customer's perspective.
FENG LU: That's right.
Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: And the
other thing I like too
is that in terms of locking down
the access to the Airflow web
server, you leverage the
Identity-Aware Proxy,
so the user can just sign in
using their IAM credentials
and gaining access that way.
They don't have to actually do
some sort of proxy tunneling
or anything like that.
FENG LU: True.
Yeah, that's the
reason why we decided
to put this in
the tenant project
and also put it behind the IAP,
so that it's always, always
accessible to you without
all the proxying set up.
One more thing I want
to mention is the reason
why we put things
in tenant project
is so that we can hide all the
IAP details from customers.
You don't have to learn IAP in
order to use Cloud Composer.
Everything is being
managed for you.
TOM MCGRATH: That's
an excellent point.
Excellent point.
And then of course, when it
comes to leveraging DAGs, which
are basically your workflows
and logs and plug-ins,
that's all done
through Cloud Storage.
And then of course, logging
goes into the Stackdriver
and we'll see that.
FENG LU: Deploying
a DAG is super easy.
Just copy a file to GCS.
That's all you need to do.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah, it's so
easy moving files to GCS,
so no problems there.
So let's see what an
actual workflow looks
like at a very high level.
It's basically a collection of
tasks with interdependencies
and relationships.
So basically, tasks
associate with workflows.
Dependencies wait until the
data is available in GCS,
for example.
And then I start
my BigQuery job.
Or it triggers something, right?
That file is actually
available within HDFS,
and let's copy it
into GCS from there.
So these are really the building
blocks of workflows in Airflow.
And then of course, maybe
when my job completes,
then I want to notify
my users on Slack
so they know that the most
up-to-date data and information
is available to them.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: So Airflow
DAGs are effectively
Python files with
five main sections,
and we'll cover each
of those in turn.
So import, right?
Step one, import.
From the Airflow system, a DAG
or a Directed Acyclic Graph
is basically another
way of saying workflow.
So we import the operators
to be used in the workflow.
For example, the
BigQuery operator
you can see there
on the fourth line.
And then from there, we can
trigger rules to specify
the intertask relationships.
Then the arguments are defined.
So we might have some
default DAG arguments,
and that's a convenient
thing for Airflow.
But if there's common
arguments that you
want to leverage, instead
of specifying those
for each Airflow
task, you can actually
specify those at the
beginning of your workflow,
and then pass them
in automatically
via the Airflow DAG model.
I think that's super cool.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
FENG LU: Saves a lot of boiler
plate coding in your workflow.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah, absolutely,
and lots of flexibility.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
So in terms of setup, you
basically give it a name--
so in this case, demo_dag--
a schedule interview
and interval, and also
default arguments.
Very simple, straightforward,
easy to understand.
And then we define the tasks.
So here you can see that we have
a BigQuery operator and also
a BigQuery to GCS operator.
So within the BigQuery
operator, we're
running a BigQuery query
that will export the results
to a new data set,
and you can see
where it's specifying the name
of the table with BigQuery.
But then we also have the
BigQuery to Cloud Storage
operator, which is
exporting that new data set
to Cloud Storage.
Once again, easy integration.
Very simple and
easy to understand.
FENG LU: Plus, the code
is not hard to read.
TOM MCGRATH: Oh, no.
Absolutely not.
Yeah, this is simple and
straightforward stuff.
That's the purpose.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
So in terms of
ordering, the tasks
can be ordered based on
completion dependencies.
One thing must finish
before the other.
For example, my
Airflow_commits_query,
the query that runs that
creates my data set,
must finish before I want
to export that data to GCS.
Makes sense.
It's that easy.
So at this point we're
going to switch to the demo.
Feng is going to
present that for us.
So take it away, Feng.
FENG LU: Thanks, Tom.
So so far we have been talking
about all the nice things
about the Cloud Composer.
Now let's see how we put
everything in action.
We mentioned that to get things
started, the first thing you
probably want to do is go to--
there a few places we mentioned
about Cloud Console.
We mentioned about a Cloud SDK.
Here we'll just
use Cloud Console
as a way to demonstrate how
to play with Cloud Composer.
A similar functionality can
be achieved using Cloud SDK.
Most of the cases, what
you want to do is just go--
once you are in the Cloud
Composer page in Cloud Console,
say you want to create
a composing environment.
Click the Create and that
leads you to the Create page.
Here you can specify your name.
Say, hey, demo.
And then you can specify all the
arguments or all the properties
of that environment.
I'm going to walk you through
some of the configuration
options that you might have.
You can always
specify the region
where you want to create
your composing environment.
You can also specify things
like a machine type, number
of nodes, all scope, and also
I want to highlight one thing.
For better isolation
and protection,
we will also allow you to
specify a service account you
use to run the
composing environment,
so you don't have to use the
generic default Compute Engine
service account.
You can use any service
account at your choice.
TOM MCGRATH: Very cool.
FENG LU: Yeah.
Scroll down a little bit.
That section is about
some Airflow configuration
properties.
And then Airflow itself
comes with a long list
of configurations.
TOM MCGRATH: How
many would you say
there are, if you had to guess?
FENG LU: I think it's probably
100-plus configuration options,
but you are not going
to use all of those.
TOM MCGRATH: Good point.
FENG LU: Say some
common ones, I would
say, if you want to
decide how soon you
want to reload your DAG file.
That's probably
something you care,
because every time
you make a change,
you want Airflow to pick
up that change quickly,
so that's something
you can config.
And moving down, we also
have environment variables.
Those are the ones if you want
to send an email right now,
a composer comes by together
with SendGrid email support.
TOM MCGRATH: Oh, nice.
FENG LU: So you would config
a composing environment
by just adding two
environment variables,
like SendGrid mail from
and SendGrid API key.
TOM MCGRATH: Very simple.
FENG LU: Those will get you
set up with email capabilities.
TOM MCGRATH: Excellent.
FENG LU: Labels-- if you want to
basically conveniently navigate
through composing environments
and even across other GC
resources, you can always use
labels attached to environments
to [INAUDIBLE] on
those labels, you
would be able to get
your environment.
I'm probably going to skip the
part of creating a composing
environment.
Reason because it may take
10-plus minutes, not because--
the reason is we need
to create an App Engine,
and it takes a while for
the App Engine to get ready.
So let's assume that you already
have the environment ready.
TOM MCGRATH: OK.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Perfect.
FENG LU: So let's go back.
So we have a composer demo
environment created beforehand.
And once you have the
environment ready,
you can go in and inspect
the various properties
of that environment.
Here you get the overview,
like how many number
of nodes, service accounts,
[INAUDIBLE] scope,
and you also get to see that
two important things here.
One is the host of
the Airflow web UI.
The second thing is
the G-SaaS packet.
The Airflow web UI allows
you to inspect workflows.
And then the G-SaaS
packet is really
for you to upload and make
changes to your DAG files.
TOM MCGRATH: Makes sense.
FENG LU: So now
let's go and take
a look at a hosted web server.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah,
let's see it in action.
FENG LU: Yeah.
So as I mentioned
earlier, the web server
is hosted in GIE,
protected by IAP.
If you first login
to this page, it
will ask you for your
Google credentials to login.
It can be your Gmail
account, or you can also
have [INAUDIBLE] access
through a web server
by using a service account.
Both ways are possible.
And then once you are
in the Airflow web UI,
you could start to inspect
the various workflows
you have submitted.
For example, earlier we have Tom
walk you through the BigQ demo.
So we can inspect and check
a few details of that.
You have a few tasks.
Those tasks are
chained in some order.
Not very fancy.
I understand it's really
like a linear chain of tasks,
but you can create it
as complicated workflows
as you want.
So for the time
now, this has really
tried to connect you back to
the example you have just seen,
right?
You create a data site,
you run BigQ query,
and then you export
the data to G-SaaS.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
I've definitely
seen customers who
are running Airflow where their
diagrams or their graph views
easily take up the whole screen.
FENG LU: Exactly, yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: So this is, of
course, a very simplistic
example, but it shows
the idea of what's
possible within Airflow.
FENG LU: Right, right.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
FENG LU: And then
there are various views
of that DAG workflow.
It has the graph view,
you've got a tree view,
and then personally
I myself also
find the [INAUDIBLE]
there's a Gantt chart view.
I'm sorry.
This one shows the timeline.
This is the Gantt chart view.
This allows you to
put all your task
completion in a single place.
You would be able to say,
hey, when a task gets started
or when--
where you spend most
time on a specific task.
TOM MCGRATH: So this
is really helpful,
because then we can basically
look at everything in one place
and understand where
the bottlenecks are.
FENG LU: Exactly, yeah.
Then you can decide from that
point, how should you optimize
your workflow pipeline?
TOM MCGRATH: Got it.
FENG LU: Yeah.
Let's go back and then
go to the homepage.
[INAUDIBLE] that's actually
you start a workflow run.
Here you can easily
trigger a workflow run
from the Airflow web page.
Once a workflow run is created,
you save the workflow runs.
The status that you have
a one run says running,
and then unfortunately
you probably
have to refresh
the page from time
to time so that you
can see a task being
moved from various stages.
TOM MCGRATH: Got it.
FENG LU: So here we have seen
that we have a task that's
right now in the running state.
It's probably done processing,
but you can go back to inspect.
There's another one.
If you go to the graph
view, you can see
the various data of the task.
And sometimes if you're
curious to understand
the logs that's
produced by the task,
you can always go inspect here.
TOM MCGRATH: And that's
a common request, too.
FENG LU: Customer request, yes.
TOM MCGRATH: A lot of users
want to be able to see the logs
and see what's going on,
especially from Airflow
when it's touching so
many different systems.
FENG LU: Exactly, and
then often sometimes
when you have task
failures, that's probably
when logs become most useful.
So we understand sometimes a
failure may come out from--
a fault may not necessarily
happen within Airflow.
Think about it.
You have a process crash.
You have a container restart.
Those events are not
uncommon in Kubernetes.
We provide Stackdriver logs
so that your logs are always
kept somewhere, even
for the logs that
happen outside Airflow.
TOM MCGRATH: Very cool.
Very helpful for debugging
and seeing what's
actually going on.
FENG LU: Right.
Yeah, so if you go to our
Stackdriver login page,
we actually have a dedicated
Cloud Composer stop there.
You can navigate there,
try to figure out which
environment, which
region, and which
environment you have your
Airflow environment created.
You can select
those environments,
and then once you have
selected your environment,
you will be able to see
all the logs pertaining
to your environments.
We tried to pre-classify those
logs into a few categories.
We have Airflow schedule
logs, worker logs.
That helps you to
better manage your logs.
One more thing we have added
to the Airflow worker logs
is we do allow you to
filter logs by DAG ID, task
ID, and execution date.
TOM MCGRATH: Ah.
FENG LU: It will
quickly help you
to navigate to the specific
task you're looking for.
TOM MCGRATH: And
then you can really
narrow your way through
the logs as opposed
to looking at everything.
FENG LU: Right.
Otherwise you're just seeing
this continuous stream of logs,
and you off--
worse that those logs you may
mix were from concurrent tasks.
TOM MCGRATH: Of
course, of course.
Because chances are you probably
have multiple different DAGs,
perhaps even sub-DAGs,
which we'll get into.
FENG LU: Absolutely.
TOM MCGRATH: It can easily
become quite complicated.
FENG LU: Exactly.
Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: But this removes
all that complication.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
FENG LU: That's how
we saw that-- how
we could Stackdriver
logging useful for you
for debugging Airflow DAGs.
TOM MCGRATH: Awesome.
FENG LU: Yeah.
Moving back, we noticed
that the BQ demo workflow
has completed successfully.
You see that--
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah,
it's not showing
that it was running anymore
in that in second slot there.
FENG LU: And there's
no alerting red circle,
or like red sign, or--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TOM MCGRATH: Always good
when you run something
and there's no red.
FENG LU: Right.
The other thing I also
want to highlight here
is in our GA release,
Cloud Composer
starts to support a
KubernetesPodOperator.
What that gives to you is
the flexibility for you
to start and run any container
within Cloud Composer.
We, for example in the past--
Tom, you probably also got
a lot of similar questions.
Like, people ask, hey, I have
this dependency that is not
really [INAUDIBLE] dependency,
how should I install and import
that dependency into Composer?
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
That's a common question--
how to configure, customize,
add in some custom
code, et cetera.
FENG LU: Right.
Now, as things become
so easy, anything
you need to do that Composer
doesn't provide to you out
of the box, just go
and create a container,
and then bring that container
to Workflow, to Composer.
TOM MCGRATH: Very nice.
FENG LU: Here, I have a kind
of simple container task.
Let's go just inspect
the code a little bit.
Scroll down-- look here.
We have KubernetesPodOperator.
And then the image we
run is very simple-- it
lets you compute Pi.
TOM MCGRATH: Very cool.
FENG LU: Yes.
But the nice thing is--
I hope the things
that's demoed here
is that, really, you
can launch a container.
And then the container
image can be anything.
TOM MCGRATH: That's
amazing for extensibility.
FENG LU: Right.
And I actually
have some good news
to share towards the
end of the session.
TOM MCGRATH: Ooh--
FENG LU: More
things you could do
is playing with containers
in Cloud Composer.
TOM MCGRATH: Oh,
well, I'm excited to--
FENG LU: I'm going to hold
that for a few minutes.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
I'm excited to hear about it.
I'm in suspense.
FENG LU: So let's go back.
And then again, let's
just do the same thing.
Let's just trigger a DAG run.
And just wait to see
everything in action.
TOM MCGRATH: So we can see it's
running in that second slot
there.
I see the bright, green circle--
FENG LU: Yeah.
It'll do a bunch of refresh.
TOM MCGRATH: [INAUDIBLE].
FENG LU: We will see
the task gradually move.
Running, to execution,
to completion.
TOM MCGRATH: Perfect.
FENG LU: And then
similarly, I want
to let everyone know
that you can also
inspect container logs.
Sometimes, you want to see
the task logs of course,
but then you may also want to
inspect the container logs.
That might be useful
for you to debug, like,
what's happening in
your container task.
TOM MCGRATH: Nice.
FENG LU: Now, we go.
The first task is done.
Now, we're moving
to a container task.
Just give 10, 15 seconds--
I think it should end.
We're doing--
TOM MCGRATH: Back.
Yeah, there you go.
Perfect.
You could also just do--
FENG LU: Control.
You can tell I don't use--
TOM MCGRATH: Team demo.
FENG LU: Team demo.
And you can tell I
don't use Pixel a lot.
TOM MCGRATH: That's OK.
FENG LU: So the task is running.
We can inspect the log.
That's one more thing I
want to highlight here,
which is perfect
from this example.
Sometimes, there might be
some delay from Airflow
when they try to collect logs
and display logs in a web UI.
Because you try to
do things in pairs
to save a lot of
read-write cost.
But then with Stackdriver,
you got logs in real time,
so you don't have to wait--
always in [? tears. ?] Imagine
that you have, like a task that
may take hours to complete,
and in the middle,
you don't want
to just wait hours-- be
able to see the logs.
TOM MCGRATH: I know.
You want to see the
logs right away.
You want to know
what's going on.
FENG LU: Yeah.
That's how stack driver
could come in and help,
so that you can inspect
logs in real time.
TOM MCGRATH: Awesome.
FENG LU: Yep.
Again, let's just give it
some time for it to finish.
Well, while we're waiting
for the demo to complete,
the other thing I
also want to mention--
things are very
useful on the Airflow
web UI is it also gives a place
for you to retrigger DAGs.
But also a common
issue people run into
is like, what if your DAG
runs into an error state
and you want to recover
from that error state?
Things you can do here is--
it's something manual, but
it's still better for you
to rerun the entire pipeline.
What do you can do is by delete
or clear the failed task.
And after that, you set
your workflow status
from failed to running.
And then after the workflow
status changed to running,
Airflow scheduler will
be able to pick up
on and then reschedule
the previous failed task.
TOM MCGRATH: Oh, that's awesome.
So you can pick up right from
exactly where the DAG left off
effectively.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: Nice.
FENG LU: We're also trying
to see how we can better
automate this
instead of you always
have to perform this
multi-step action yourself.
But at least there's a way
for you to do that right now
in Airflow.
TOM MCGRATH: Absolutely.
All right, let's
see how it's doing.
Oh, look at that.
[LAUGHING]
FENG LU: Look at the very end.
This computes the value of Pi.
TOM MCGRATH: I was going
to say that looks like Pi.
[LAUGHING]
FENG LU: Yeah, that is Pi.
TOM MCGRATH: There we go.
Perfect.
FENG LU: Yeah.
That's pretty much
about a demo session.
So coming back, I do want
to quickly recap what
we have discussed in the demo.
We have created a composing
environment-- walks you
through the various
configuration options.
We have also shown you how you
could inspect your workflows
in Airflow web UI, and then
some of the common tasks
you could perform
using Airflow web UI,
like triggering a DAG run,
inspecting log details.
And then sometimes, if you
need to get a little bit more
debugging with [INAUDIBLE]
Stackdriver as well,
you can get those information.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
I can definitely see
how, through this demo,
we are definitely taking
care of and meeting
a lot of those challenges
that we talked about earlier.
FENG LU: Right.
So earlier, we mentioned that
the way how Airflow [INAUDIBLE]
DAGs is really code.
So with code, it opens up a
lot of possibilities for you
to do more funny stuff here.
One thing is you could template.
Many cases-- hey, my workflow
remains 99% unchanged.
I only need to touch this single
parameter with each invocation
of my diagram.
So that's what's supporting
Airflow was templating.
Just put whatever
parameter you need
to templarise as an
encapsulating [INAUDIBLE]
template.
And then you can
always instantiate
that as a DAG runtime.
TOM MCGRATH: Awesome.
FENG LU: Yeah.
Likewise, if your
DAG is complicated--
think about if you have 500--
you mentioned that you
have seen some DAG examples
with like a few hundred tasks.
TOM MCGRATH: At least.
[LAUGHING]
FENG LU: I realize it is so
tedious and probably also error
prone for you to specify
those DAGs or tasks one by one
yourself.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah, definitely.
FENG LU: So here's another way.
You can use programmatic
DAG generation
where everything's been
done in your program.
And that's also one of
the motivations behind why
we want to use programming
languages to define and then
create DAGs.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, if I had to run
1,000 tasks of the same type,
that would just be so tedious.
And you know, with few lines
of code, we're able to do that.
FENG LU: Right.
And then the last thing is
when your DAGs has grown big,
you want modularity.
You want to be able to
create sub-components.
Airflow has this concept
called subDAG that conveniently
allows you to package a few
related tasks into a single sub
DAG.
And no single sub
DAG will be treated
as if they're a single
task in the master DAG.
TOM MCGRATH: That's
awesome for reusability.
FENG LU: Reusability
and it also helps
you to organize your tasks
in a hierarchical manner.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah.
FENG LU: Cool.
So those are all
the nice things you
could do using Airflow, using
Composer, using its programming
model to define the workflows.
Some of the common questions we
have seen from our customers,
can I install Python packages?
We have just discussed that.
In fact, often
more than that, you
can bring any containers
into a composer
where you can capture
your dependencies there.
TOM MCGRATH: And something
that's interesting,
right, is when you do that, when
you place your custom packages
and custom code inside
that DAG folder,
we actually recognize that
it's not actually a DAG.
It doesn't have those
beginning DAG statements
that we talked about earlier,
so airflow doesn't pick it up
as a DAG.
FENG LU: Exactly.
TOM MCGRATH: That's cool.
FENG LU: Environment will be
auto-upgraded on our roadmap.
Not supported right
now, but that's
something we're
working very hard on.
Will our Composer be
offered in more regions?
Absolutely, yes.
That's our roadmap
to expand Composer
to possibly one or two more
regions by the end of the year.
TOM MCGRATH: And I think GA
is a good example of that,
right, because with
the GA release,
it was then available
in two more regions.
FENG LU: Right.
Is there a graphic
way to create DAGs?
We hear you.
Yes.
[LAUGHING]
Absolutely.
TOM MCGRATH: Work in progress.
FENG LU: Yeah, working
on-- in progress.
We also want to make sure that
for the people who are not
very comfortable
with programming--
although we mentioned that
Airflow DAG model is really
simple, but still, if you
prefer to use GUI for creating
your DAGs, that's something
we see a value in,
and we're working on.
TOM MCGRATH: Definitely.
FENG LU: Can I choose
which version of Python
is using Composer?
Yes, the support is
going to be out soon.
Well, you could specify
whether you want
to use Python 2 or Python 3.
TOM MCGRATH: Stay
tuned for that one.
FENG LU: Exactly.
Sort of a broader scheme or
grand scheme of Composer,
where we are heading
to, definitely
want to see more close
Kubernetes and Airflow
integrations.
As I mentioned, I want to
save something at the end.
So here we can use--
TOM MCGRATH: Oh, here we go.
FENG LU: Yeah.
Soon, we're going to
make another release.
In another release,
we're going to allow
you to create GKE clusters--
deleted GK clusters.
And also, more importantly,
you can launch a container
in any GK cluster as long
as you have credentials.
TOM MCGRATH: That's awesome.
FENG LU: So think about that.
We know, like GK just
promoted its GKE On-Prem,
where if you could orchestrate
in a launcher container
in a remote cluster that
is hosted in your On-Prem,
eventually, that gives you
a convenient way for you
to build hybrid
orchestration in GCP.
TOM MCGRATH: And that
definitely makes sense.
There's definitely a number
of customers out there
who do want to
continue to leverage
their on-prem investments.
FENG LU: Exactly.
We see that.
So we think like, using GKE
On-Prem might be a good bridge
to connect it to.
TOM MCGRATH: Definitely.
FENG LU: We're also looking
at adding more operators.
This year, we plan to add
another 20 or 30 GCP service
related operators into Airflow.
TOM MCGRATH: Very cool.
FENG LU: And resource usage.
We definitely want to see
more resource elasticity,
ideally to the
state where if you
don't have any
workflow executing,
you don't have to pay anything.
That would be our final goal.
TOM MCGRATH: That makes sense.
And obviously, you
constrain the amount
needed or consumed based on
usage and based on needs.
FENG LU: Exactly.
TOM MCGRATH: Definitely
consistent with our managed
services.
FENG LU: Right.
So with all that being said,
how should I get started today?
There are a few places
you can get resources.
Our Apache Airflow website
has organized tutorials
and information
covering the basics.
And some of the examples
are in the website.
But also, we have a
lot more sample code,
how-tos, and then
also the ways how
to interconnect with
other GCP services
in our Cloud Composer
Cloud doc website.
TOM MCGRATH: Cool.
FENG LU: With that,
that will be--
TOM MCGRATH: That's a wrap.
FENG LU: Yeah.
So stay tuned for live Q&A,
and we will be back with you
in less than a minute.
OK.
And we're back with some
questions from the audience.
So I think one of the
first questions that's
pretty interesting
is what should I
consider when deciding
whether to use Cloud Composer
or Dataflow?
And I think one
of the key things
there is to clarify
that Cloud Composer is
really more about
orchestration and making things
happen within various systems,
whereas Dataflow is more
for processing and ETLing both
streaming and batch data moving
into some sort of data
sink as necessary.
But because of all those
operators within Airflow
and available within
Cloud Composer,
I can see it's very
easy to say, well, gosh,
couldn't I use Cloud
Composer as an ETL tool?
And that would probably not
be the best way to proceed.
FENG LU: Right.
And the way I would
also call this will be--
Composer will be a control flow
orchestration system, where
Dataflow is more--
obviously, very data centric,
data processing focused.
TOM MCGRATH: Yeah, definitely.
And so another question
that we received
is, what are some
of the reasons why
it would be difficult
to run airflow myself
and I should consider leveraging
cloud composer instead?
And my understanding is
that when it comes time
to install, and run it,
and things like that,
that can take a lot of effort.
FENG LU: Right.
Try to create a [INAUDIBLE]
yourself and you
will see all [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHING]
Think about it.
You also need to
upgrade dependencies,
especially if you try to
run Airflow in a distributed
environment.
Every time you try
to install a package,
you have to make sure that it's
installing all your instances
or services.
TOM MCGRATH: Got it.
FENG LU: And think
about how would you
be able to consistently
distribute your DAGs to all
your Airflow instances.
TOM MCGRATH: Makes sense.
FENG LU: Those are really
tricky and hard to manage
by yourself problems.
TOM MCGRATH: Big challenges.
And how much effort
do you actually
want to put into making those
things work is the question.
FENG LU: Yeah.
We really want you to
be able to say, hey,
I want to use Airflow--
10 minutes after that, you
can start using Airflow
by writing your first DAG
without worrying about, hmm,
how should I install my
Airflow on GCP or other cloud
providers?
TOM MCGRATH: Makes sense.
And another interesting
one is there
is a KubernetesPodOperator.
That would work with
Kubeflow, right,
for running ML models
and things like that?
FENG LU: Absolutely.
As I mentioned, there was the
GKE pod operator that also
is the concern of resources.
And you probably
don't have to force
to run your container
in the same cluster
where you run your
composing environment.
You can launch your
task in any GKE cluster.
Presumably some of the ones--
you might already be using
those to run Kubeflows.
TOM MCGRATH: Definitely.
And something I think
that's specifically
interesting with
Kubeflow is if you
think of all the
data engineering that
goes into creating
an ML model, I mean,
Cloud Composer
becomes a natural fit
to orchestrate those
tasks end to end.
That's really awesome.
FENG LU: Yeah.
TOM MCGRATH: What other
questions do we have?
Can I kick off a DAG
based on time of day
or from a Cloud Function?
FENG LU: Yes, I think.
[LAUGHING]
From a day, for sure, and
from a cloud function, yes.
That's one thing I want to say--
why we decided to host Airflow
web server in this way.
Hosting it in [INAUDIBLE]
and also [INAUDIBLE]
gives you two things.
One is that Airflow web
UI is publicly accessible,
but with a security
protection in front.
So from Cloud function--
in fact, we have a tutorial
on our Cloud doc website
that talks about how you
can trigger a DAG execution,
we'll have it as
a GCS file change.
So it works like,
you have GCS change,
your trigger a GCS call, and
that GCS call makes an HTTP
POST request to the
composing environment,
and then it starts
the DAG execution.
TOM MCGRATH: Perfect.
Maybe I have some
data landing in GCS,
and then I want to import
that into BigQuery,
and then do something
with it from there.
FENG LU: Right.
Also, I just want to tie that
with the templating things
we have discussed.
So with [INAUDIBLE] like
HTTP DAG triggering,
you can also send along
parameters or configuration
values.
Those will all get instantiated
together with each DAG run.
TOM MCGRATH: That's awesome.
Really cool.
And then really quickly with
the KubernetesPodOperator
is it possible to
startup the cluster
and then shut it down
when the sensor recognizes
that the task is complete?
FENG LU: Wow, that sounds
like a lot of work.
[LAUGHING]
I would say, yes, you can do it.
But then you have to
really start a container
and then actually
talk to GKE service.
To save all that
trouble for you,
we have these GKE
cluster operators
that allows you to easily
just create and delete it.
We'll update GKE clusters
from Cloud Composer.
TOM MCGRATH: Excellent.
Very cool.
Well, thank you for
joining us at "Google Cloud
OnAir," with new live
webinars every Tuesday.
We hope you have a
great day, and we
hope you enjoy
working with composer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]